foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar digital
PCR foundations I am Michelle Ashton of
Labor roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Dave Bauer qpcr and dpcr Fields
application scientist at Thermo Fisher
Scientific
Dr Bauer you may now begin your
presentation
all right thank you for the introduction
so we will be talking about digital PCR
Basics today
and a quick overview of what we're going
through we'll talk just in general what
digital PCR is some comparisons of
digital PCR to real-time PCR
and also understanding the workflow for
specifically the Quant Studio absolute Q
digital PCR instrument and then we'll
finish off with some common applications
and areas where digital can be very
valuable to use
what is digital PCR
it's a method to quantify nucleic acid
targets without standard curves so let
me just pause that sentence right there
and if we just think about the beginning
part of quantifying or even assessing
nucleic acid targets that ability has
been around for a while even going back
to traditional or bulk PCR with the gel
in those cases
in Lanes two three and four we can see
that our Target was present and in Lane
five it was absent
and then the next advancement in PCR
came with quantitative or real-time PCR
in this case as the name real time
suggests we're not just doing an end
point measurement but we're actually
looking at the PCR reaction as a
function of PCR Cycles so we get that
whole curve showing the kinetics and
efficiency of the amplification
and you might be thinking I've done
quote unquote absolute quantification
with real-time PCR keep in mind though
real-time PCR is specifically a relative
measure the output we get the CT value
or cycle threshold value it's a relative
measure and generally needs to be
compared to other CT values for meaning
and this is where the latter half of
that sentence up top comes into play
where we can do this without standard
curves and that's accomplished by
dividing the bulk reaction into many
sub-reactions and in this case thousands
and thousands of them
and in that case when we've done our PCR
cycling we don't get any real-time
information but rather with digital PCR
it's more analogous to a gel where we
get more of a binary yes no do I see
amplification or not
all right so let's look at some of the
strengths of digital PCR so for starters
as we mentioned digital PCR we can
quantify our sample without the need for
any reference or standard curves
additionally digital PCR is really great
at detecting rare targets amongst a sea
of wild type often called the looking
for the needle in a haystack problem
and there's also a linear response in
digital PCR compared to the logarithmic
response and signal with real-time PCR
this makes detecting very small changes
very helpful so even if you're not doing
absolute quantification but just
relative such as gene expression or copy
number variation digital PCR can still
be very beneficial there over real time
and we also have single molecule
resolution so not only can the
instrument detect and quantify the
presence of a single Target but another
value is that we can also confirm that
positive counts where a Target is seen
we can actually find out if those counts
are in the same physical
microchamber or sub-reaction so we can
actually get a lot more information
about not only is the sequence present
in my sample but is it present and also
physically linked to the other targets
I'm detecting this opens up a much wider
range of questions that we can tackle
with digital PCR
as well as an improved tolerance to
Inhibitors
we'll talk about that point specifically
and many of these points on the slide
going forward so just wanted to
introduce them here as they will be kind
of repeated themes as we go through
so let's do a little more Deep dive on
digital PCR compared to real time
so they're both methods to assess or
quantify nucleic acids and they use
really the same underlying biochemistry
so whatever we're using for real-time
PCR all of the master mix components are
template DNA that's really going to be
pretty much the same with digital PCR
the underlying biochemistry isn't
different
however it's the data collection is a
big difference we don't actually need
amplification curves so we're not
dependent on reaction kinetics or the
efficiency of the PCR reaction when
we're talking about digital PCR because
it's just the end point detection
so let's dive a little bit deeper into
the comparison of digital PCR in real
time
so starting on the right on this of this
line real-time PCR does have its areas
where it can be beneficial compared to
digital
so for example developing assays as I
mentioned on the previous slide that
we're detecting with real-time PCR the
kinetics of the reaction and that can
sometimes be valuable for assay
development
or let's say you were just doing
relative quantification looking for a 10
or 50 full change in gene expression
that might be sufficient to do real time
or if there's a large number of targets
or large number of samples that we're
trying to assess
additionally if we're simply trying to
confirm if a Target is there or not
present or absent
in that case real time might be fully
sufficient
one other big value of real-time PCR in
the middle of the slide here is the
dynamic range real-time PCR has a large
working dynamic range where we can
detect a handful of molecules copies of
our Target all the way up to millions or
billions of copies of our Target in the
sample the dynamic range of real-time
is very beneficial for that
digital PCR it's going to be a smaller
dynamic range but it's a it's more
geared toward the lower concentrations
so anytime we're working with lower
concentration targets that's where
digital is potentially going to be more
likely to have greater value
and so looking at that less that list on
the left measuring rare targets of
course
and as we've alluded to multiple times
whenever absolute quantification is
needed that's where digital is coming to
shine
and because of that Precision that we
referenced we have the ability to
monitor small changes whether that's
over time or between samples
and multiplexing we'll talk about later
how multiplexing can be easier with
digital compared to real time primarily
because we don't rely on the reaction
kinetics
and lastly quantifying standards for
real-time PCR so you notice the bottom
left of the slide and the top right
those are complementary things I don't
want you to walk away from this thinking
should I use digital or real time
sometimes the answer is going to be both
they do have kind of a yin and yang
complement in certain workflows
so let's step back and just look at the
data collection for digital PCR and
we'll start by looking at it for real
time and then go from there for
comparison
so as we alluded to earlier the big
difference is the efficiency of PCR that
is a huge huge aspect of real-time data
collection so that plot on the graph is
showing
if we had a sample where the efficiency
was at 100
that line would cross the Threshold at a
certain place giving us a certain CT
value but if that same sample or that
same concentration was in the presence
of Inhibitors that line instead might be
kind of less Steep and that's going to
impact the CT value that's where
real-time PCR is very vulnerable to
inhibitors for this reason
but with digital PCR we're not looking
at the progression of the reaction we're
not getting CT values we're just making
the binary distinction of do I see
signal or not so basically we're looking
at the very end of that graph as long as
the Blue Line got above the Baseline
noise that's a sufficient amount of
application for Digital PCR to do what
it needs to
so let's look more at data generation
for real-time PCR so let's just zoom in
on one well in our plate so in this case
we have our bulk reaction there might be
one target molecule or tons and tons of
them but for each Target molecule
present that one copy at cycle one is
going to get Amplified for cycle two and
so on and so on so that by cycle 40 we
have tons of copies tons of signal
generated from that starting amplicon
and the real-time PCR output which is an
amplification curve
and so there is the progression of
signal over the 40 Cycles
but now let's say I wasn't trying to
quantify anything at this point I just
wanted to say
or ask is my target there or not well
just looking at cycle 40 alone from the
real-time data we can see when there was
Target present the signal went up so at
cycle 40 it was elevated compared to
when there is no target present its
signal stays at Baseline so we can
differentiate just from the endpoint
measurement if Target was there or not
so keeping that idea in mind let's now
switch to digital PCR instead of running
the entire reaction in one bulk set
let's take the liquid illustrated by
that purple box coming out of the h12
position on the plate and then dividing
that out into thousands and thousands of
sub-reactions in that grid there and
these sub-reactions are physically
isolated from one another
good
and so with that physical isolation now
if we have a particular
sub-reaction that had Target present
then after PCR thermal cycling we're
going to see
signal in that particular location but
because we divided that sample up into
so many reactions they're going to be
pretty small volumes less than a
nanoliter at that point we expect that
some of those sub-reactions actually
won't have any Target presence and the
sub-reactions that don't have Target
will not give a signal
and now if we look at actual data from
the absolute Q instrument this is what
it would look like the endpoint
measurement we see that for any of those
isolated sub-reactions where we have
some Target present in the beginning we
get the fluorescence shown in green
and then for any sub-reactions that were
empty of Target we don't see anything
and as you would intuitively assume if
you have a higher Target concentration
you'll have more fluorescent reactions
whereas if you have a lower Target
concentration you'll see fewer
fluorescent reactions
so this view here on the left is showing
the full array from one instrument run
in this case there are 20
480 microchambers or sub-reactions that
the one sample got split up into
and so if we zoom into one little
section we can see the bright squares
and the dark squares
and this information alone is what's
used to get the absolute concentration
of our Target so we typically look at
this data
as a scatter plot where that horizontal
axis represents the 20 000 plus
microchambers the vertical axis is the
fluorescence intensity and what we want
to see is a nice separation where we
have high signal and then somewhere else
low signal
and as long as we can differentiate
positives from negatives we can then get
a concentration
so all we need from digital PCR is a
count of how many of those sub-reactions
were positive in this example
3630 were positive out of 20
466. those numbers alone get us to the
concentration of 468 copies per Mark
liter
and this is done relying on poisson
statistics the reason that we need to
incorporate that is because we can't
just naively assume that every
fluorescent chamber
corresponds to exactly one target
molecule that might not be the case and
that's where poisson statistics can help
so just to kind of briefly Give an
example about poisson statistics
let's talk about a quick example a
little hypothetical here
let's say I have this grid of squares on
the table and I have a cup of red balls
I dump the red balls into the grid
and let's assume that we have the same
number of red balls as we have squares
in the grid so the effective
quote-unquote concentration of one ball
per square if I were to dump those out
on the table I don't think anyone
expects to see exactly one ball in every
single square instead we know that
there's going to be some Randomness that
some squares will be empty some will
have one ball two Etc
for some statistics can help because it
tells us knowing that average
concentration of one ball per square
denoted by that Lambda symbol having an
average of one
using poisson statistics we can tell
what that distribution of how many balls
in each Square would be how it percent
would be zero or have one two Etc
and if we change that concentration
let's say I used twice as many balls per
square then we have a Lambda or
concentration of two on average and in
that case would be a different
distribution and so on and so on for any
effective concentration we would get a
different distribution here
but the kit the catch is with digital
PCR we can't actually measure the whole
distribution all we can really see is if
a spot was empty or if it was not empty
one or more
so that vertical dashed red line going
through the graphs separates what we can
actually see with a digital PCR
measurement
so in reality our digital PCR it would
look more like this where we can't tell
how many balls are in the squares but we
can tell which squares are empty and not
empty and thankfully with the sun
statistics that is still enough
information to get an estimate on the
concentration if we just know the
proportion
that are empty in this example 37 of the
squares were empty percent statistics
gives us the equation to plug that
number in
we plug in that 37 percent that gives us
one ball per square we're thinking back
to digital PCR now one copy per chamber
and now one copy per chamber still isn't
the most meaningful measurement we want
something more like copies per
microliter which is an easy conversion
as well so just by knowing simply the
percentage of microchambers that are
empty we can infer what the
concentration was
so now let's talk about the digital PCR
workflow
specifically as it relates to the
absolute Q instrument
so preparing our samples is going to be
a lot like real-time PCR or even pretty
close to traditional PCR with a gel
we're mixing up the components the
biochemistry to make PCR happen
but with digital PCR as we as we've
talked about
we then need to have that sample divided
into the thousands and thousands of
sub-reactions
then there is thermal PCR cycling which
then lets us see which of those spots
are
containing our Target and which ones are
not and this is where the idea or the
name digital comes from we're separating
out the sample so that we have tiny
little mini versions of that sample and
then we're making that binary yes no or
digital one zero
check to see which spots have our sample
or our Target and which ones do not
after the thermal cycling has occurred
some of those microchambers will be
fluorescent that information is captured
and then finally those counts of
positive and negative are made to get a
concentration
and it's the way that the reaction is
subdivided for digital piece here that
really is one of the defining features
for different instruments that are out
there
the way we divide the sample is critical
to all the steps that have to happen
before before as well as after and it
also critically impacts what level of
data quality or data quality control
metrics we can have in place depending
on what technology we're using to divide
the sample up
for the Quant Studio absolute Q
instrument
the heart of that is the plate the map
16 or microphotic plate with these 16
arrays
this contains a lot of the technology
here that gives us the ability to
separate that sample out into those
individual thousands and thousands of
microchambers
and with this map 16 plate this process
is very repeatable we get a consistent
number of microchambers created and this
is also done completely hands off from
the user
so that map 16 plate again that's 16
arrays or 16 samples that we can look at
per plate but the instrument gives you
the flexibility to actually run subsets
of the Plate at a Time in intervals of
four
so one column two column three columns
or four columns can be run on a given
experiment which means you don't have to
wait and batch your samples so that you
run all 16 and then avoiding any wasted
plate usage in this case you can run a
partial plate get some information and
then run the next plate which is really
helpful for either low throughput Labs
or when you're doing method development
where you just want to change one
variable see its impact and then try the
next iteration
and inside of each of those 16 arrays
these images here are showing a zoom in
looking at the actual microfluidic
system so you can see for a given array
there are twenty thousand four hundred
and eighty fixed Chambers these Chambers
are physically defined by the geometry
of the plate itself in the microfluidic
system
and inside of that array
will contain nine microliters of our
loaded PCR reaction mix
and what's important
to notice is that we're not really
wasting sample over 95 percent of that
nine microliters that we input is
actually going to get utilized and
assessed in our digital PCR reaction and
in our data collection
so very little dead volume here
and part of that comes from the fact
that we have such a consistent
successful micro chamber fell fill rate
micro Chambers we're going to be
utilizing pretty close to 20 480 every
time
and all of that combined gives us the
confidence to know that we have precise
repeatable measurements which is
important for accuracy and consistency
so from the user's point of view the way
this process looks they would take a
standard pipette
add nine microliters of the reaction mix
into one of the loading ports
then with a standard pipette again add
15 microliters of a special isolation
buffer
after those two simple Strokes of a
pipette we can then place these rubber
gaskets over the plate openings
and place the plate into the instrument
and that really is all that's required
of the user it's a very hands-off
process from here the instrument is
going to take over take the plate do all
of the necessary uh separating of into
the sub samples using its special
pressurized system to move the fluid
through the microfluidics it's also
going to do thermal cycling with the
heat block that's in there and capture
the fluorescence data all of that occurs
without any further intervention from
the user
so just some key takeaways about the
absolute Q instrument
most of this list we've talked about the
ones I haven't hit on yet the quick time
to results that whole process I just
described is done within around 90
minutes so you get data quickly
so if you do have a large number of
samples you need to do you can run many
many plates throughout the day
also multiplexing we'll talk shortly
about this how multiplexing gives you
more information per run the absolute Q
is a five color system one of the colors
is for Quality check and then the other
four are available for Target
multiplexing
and the system has a unique ability for
auto false positive rejection which
means we can have great confidence in
our data which is extremely important
when you're dealing with low
concentrations for each positive spot
each fluorescent signal we really need
to know that it was truly because of our
Target and not other artifacts
let's turn to some common digital PCR
applications
so this slide is showing absolute
quantification rare Target Copy number
gene expression multiplexing
all places where digital PCR can be very
valuable and any of those applications
can be applied to a range of research
areas we'll touch upon a few but some
common ones are cancer research cell and
gene therapy as well as Wastewater
testing
so with digital PCR one of its key
strengths is the ability to absolutely
quantify Target so let's talk about that
a little bit more
and again you heard me say this in the
beginning you might be thinking I've
either done or seen or heard of someone
doing quote unquote absolute
quantification with real-time PCR
while that can be done keep in mind it
was still a relative measure so there
are a couple caveats when we're doing
absolute quantification with real-time
PCR
one is the fact that we need this
reference standard
so we need to have a range of
concentrations of some reference Target
that is supposed to represent our sample
and sometimes it's not easily available
to get reference material that is a good
representation of your particular sample
or Target
and so it is important to know and keep
in mind that you're making a relative
measure from a sample type that's a
reference to the sample type that's an
unknown and if there's something about
those that are different whether one
contains maybe some Inhibitors or
there's something in the Matrix itself
if that impacts the PCR efficiency
that's going to impact your
quantification
as well as the accuracy so in the graph
there you're seeing we have our
references those orange dots shown
but you need to know ahead of time from
some other orthogonal technique what was
the concentration of your reference
standard and sometimes that's not always
a reliable number or it can be difficult
to determine
and another consideration is
repeatability because we're doing a
relative measure that relative being
from the standard curve itself any
variability in the standard curve is
going to impart variability in your
unknown samples measurement so different
analysts different users different Labs
different lots of references all of this
can impact how repeatable our
measurements will be for a given unknown
sample
and of course workflow finally just
looking at the top right the standard
curves you have to put those onto your
plate they consume time resources
reagents money
and you have to repeatedly set those up
as good practice such as another extra
level of
impact on the workflow
the slides just summarizing everything
we just went over with the drawbacks of
standard curve
now let's turn to digital PCR for
absolute quantification
so if we're doing absolute
quantification generally the need is for
some consistent precise and accurate
quantification of our Target
and for all those reasons we just
mentioned all those drawbacks with
real-time PCR
digital gets around those because again
it's a direct measurement there's no
standards that we're comparing to we're
directly assessing concentration
so one example of where you care about
absolute quantification let's say we
have some viral vectors that we're
developing and we need to quantify how
much of our usable factor is present in
our formulation
this example here
is showing a case where we're looking at
the aav or do you know Associated virus
and quantifying it over a dilution
Series so starting out with really high
concentration doing several tenfold
dilutions
we can see that at the very high
concentrations the green clusters in the
middle of the slide although most of
them are positive at the highest
concentration and we see the progressive
decrease as we go rightward to lower
concentrations
what's important here is that the plot
in the upper right corner is showing
that we have good linearity here so
these are just simple dilutions we
expect the concentrations to change
accordingly and that's indeed what we're
seeing over these four orders of
magnitude change in concentration
digital PCR can be very effective at
quantifying Targets
so with digital PCR we also have the
ability to do multiplexing
as I alluded to this earlier
multiplexing means we can get a lot more
information from a given run
so that multiplexing you can use that
for extra redundancy in your experiment
maybe you have the same or different
targets where you expect the same
concentration gives you more Assurance
in the measurement that we're getting
out
or if you want to build in some
additional internal controls whatever
options you think of they'll be
beneficial to make the experiment better
with multiplexing
additionally digital PCR can do more
than just tell you the concentration of
the different targets it can also tell
you if they're physically attached to
one another something that real-time PCR
wouldn't be able to do
so for example if I have some viral
genome and I've picked four different
locations represented by these four
different colors
I would expect for intact molecules that
were any marker chambers that have blue
signal would also have green yellow and
red and that's something our software
allows you to assess as well so you can
confirm for molecular intactness of
genomes not just their presence or
concentration that can be really helpful
if you are building a viral Vector where
maybe you need to confirm that is the
backbone sequence there and then my
insert and then any other parts that
should be
thank you
all right so let's turn now to rare
Target detection
so digital pcr's strength is the ability
to quantify at low concentrations so
real time might be able to still give
you a more qualitative assessment but
with digital we not only get the
qualitative but we're getting that
quantitative information at very low
concentrations
digital PCR also also has the Precision
to give you reliable and monitor
reliable changes in concentration at
those low concentrations
so some common uses where that might be
important if we're doing single cell
analysis or for maybe trying to detect
small residual amounts of something that
shouldn't be there like residual host
cell DNA or other contaminants where we
need that low level detection
or there's been a lot of applications of
using Wastewater surveillance with
digital PCR maybe we can actually look
at changes in the SARS Kobe 2 genome in
Wastewater to help get more information
about what's happening at the community
level
and in those cases that Target is going
to be pretty dilute when we look at the
overall Wastewater system
another use case is liquid biopsies for
oncology research excuse me ontology
research
so in this case we might be looking at
circulating tumor DNA that's in the
blood
one of the values of using a liquid
biopsy is just the ease of obtaining
from the patient
that means you can get more frequent
checks to get more information about
relative changes
something else that can be valuable with
digital PCR here is when you're looking
for rare targets but not just rare
targets rare targets that are going to
be in a sea of very similar sequences
digital PCR has a huge advantage in the
fact that it subdivides the bulk sample
making an effective increase in
sensitivity
for any of those marker chambers that do
have the rare Target present
so looking at an example of oncology
research looking at liquid biopsies
again one of the motivations for the
value of a liquid biopsy is it's
non-invasive it also gives you a better
picture of the tumor overall
so at the biological level if you were
to just take a solid piece of tumor it
might not be representative of the full
homogeneity of that sample but the
liquid biopsy can contain little
fragments from different places on the
tumor and giving you a more Fuller
picture
and again mentioning that the ability to
detect a sequence that's very similar
to the normal or wild type sequence so a
lot of times with these cancer markers
we might be looking at a single base
pair change where the liquid biopsy is
completely full full loaded of the wild
type or normal sequence and we're trying
to find the cases where there's that
single base pair change and that's what
we're interested in so having the
ability to see that needle in the
haystack is really important and valued
with digital PCR
so here's an actual example where this
was put to use so in this case there was
a
a patient where they had cancer and we
can see in the graft to the right there
was developed an assay to use digital
PCR to monitor a sequence that
represents those tumor cells and a drug
was applied that wasn't very effective
and that could be Quantified and
monitored based on the digital PCR
results but then the second treatment it
was seen that had a great impact a
severe reduction in the tumor sequence
concentration
and that information can be very useful
to monitor treatment efficacy and also
to look if there is
progression to any further stages or
reoccurrences of the cancer after
therapy or after treatment
and so this plot is just showing you can
see the tumor marker sequence dropping
down and then also remaining low so if
we're trying to
get early indications of any tumor
markers it's important to have that
sensitivity because the lower we can
detect that means the earlier we are in
the tumor progression the more valuable
that information can be
and Thermo Fisher actually offers a wide
range of pre-designed and also wet lab
tested liquid biopsy digital PCR assays
and these wet lab tested assays they
have the data showing that we can detect
down to as low as 0.1 percent mutant
allele frequency or MAF and so in these
plots here you can see on the log y
scale we're getting down to just a
handful of Target
molecule detections amongst the tens to
hundreds of thousands of the wild type
sequence
and all of those assays they can be
easily implemented into a workflow where
we have the liquid biopsy sample
collected some kind of pre-processing to
clean up the sample extract DNA and then
that sample is run on the digital PCR
system
and again mentioning that the digital
Pizza system takes care of all the sub
steps of digital PCR very hands-off from
the user and then outputs the
information that we need in terms of
those mutant allele frequencies
and so with that a little reminder that
we have a lot of information on our
website if we go to thermofisher.com
give PCR you can look at all the
different aspects of the instrument as
well as related reagents and
pre-designed assays that are available
and with that I'll turn it over if there
are any questions at this point
a for your informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
your first question is
you mentioned that the absolute cue can
support up to four targets per reaction
developing a successful three or four
Plex real-time PCR essay can be tricky
how does digital PCR compare to
real-time PCR for multiplexing
yeah so
we talk on a couple slides about how the
efficiency or the kinetics of the
real-time assay are important when
you're dealing with CT values for
real-time PCR
and when you're multiplexing if you've
ever developed a high level Multiplex
you may have seen the difficulty of
balancing those four different assays
trying to work together in the same
reaction without interfering with one
another and so a lot of times it can be
a bit of an R into dialing all the knobs
to the right value to get all the assays
to work effectively together the reason
it's such a precise tuning is because
again you don't want to interfere with
the efficiency of any of those reactions
for real time
but with digital PCR we're not as
concerned or dependent on the exact
efficiency of the assay if we Multiplex
some things together and the efficiency
does get a bit compromised for one of
the targets as long as we're still
getting enough signal to go beyond
Baseline and see the present versus
absent marker Chambers we can still get
accurate quantification with digital PCR
in that case
okay great thank you all right your next
question
um since the dynamic range of digital
PCR is smaller than real-time VCR how
confident can we be that our
measurements are within the dynamic
range of the instrument
yeah so that's an important factor and I
did mention that the dynamic range is
smaller with digital compared to
real-time PCR
and if you're on the low end of the
dynamic range it'll be pretty obvious
because you're going to be getting a
very low concentration
and if you're at the high end as you get
higher and higher in concentration
there's going to be more variability or
more uncertainty in that concentration
and that's where researchers can often
be concerned is at the high end or it
might not be as intuitive if they're too
high or not
but thankfully the digital PCR software
for the absolute queue utilizes poisson
statistics to not only get us a
concentration the copies per microlator
but also is able to use poisson
statistics to give us and calculate an
uncertainty in our folding 95 confidence
interval and that's being determined on
a sample per sample measurement per
measurement basis using the number of
targets that were found in that
experiment based on how many total
microchambers there were
so for each concentration that's
reported in the software you'll get a
confidence interval as well and so then
you can directly see
in your measurements if I'm getting an
uncertainty that's simply larger than I
would be comfortable with you'll know
that you can then just dilute that
sample run it again because as you get
to lower concentrations your relative
Precision is going to be better
and that's also reminds me of something
I commonly tell customers if they aren't
quite sure about where the concentration
is going to be of the sample they're
dealing with and they're concerned with
this issue instead of running technical
replicates on digital PCR I advise to
run delusional replicates take that
sample and run it as is and then also do
a 10 or 100 full dilution of it as well
and run that as on the same experiment
or even a different experiment and then
you'll get more information and if one
of those is outside of the dynamic range
the other one could be and if they're
both inside the dynamic range you should
see great agreement between them and get
even more confidence in your measurement
fantastic thank you your next question
how does the instrument perform the
mentioned Auto false positive rejection
yeah the auto false positive rejection
is important for any experiment but it's
really critical when we're talking about
rare targets because again with rare
targets if you're only expecting or
commonly seeing 10 of those marker
Chambers being lit up you really want to
know that all 10 of those are true
positives because two of them being
false positives can have a huge impact
on the relative difference in our answer
so the absolute Q system has actually
two ways to help with that
with auto false positives uh one is that
the instrument actually takes two images
so there's the end point detection image
that we've been talking about but
there's actually another image
collection step really early on in PCR
cycling to get the background
fluorescence levels from that particular
sample on that particular plate and this
is collected for every single individual
experiment and then subtracted out
from the end point
uh image so that means if there was any
fluorescent artifact present it would
get subtracted away meaning it would not
contribute to a false positive because
it would get subtracted out and there's
also another more sophisticated layer
where the software isn't just looking at
the overall intensity of fluorescence
it's also looking at the inside that
image the pixel by pixel
intensity of fluorescent signal that
distribution of fluorescence intensity
within the marker chamber and it knows
that there's certain patterns that
represent real PCR amplification versus
perhaps an artifact so that's also used
to make sure that things called as
positive
truly reflect PCR fluorescence not
artifacts
all right thank you Dave we've got time
for a couple more questions
your next question do I need to redesign
my existing real-time PCR assays or
change how I typically design assays to
use absolute Q
I generally know the oh the underlying
biochemistry is really the same from
digital and real-time PCR
so if you have PCR assays that you or
real-time PSIs that you've been using
those generally can be used with digital
PCR with no optimization no change
no change I have walked into plenty of
customer labs and we just wanted to try
the real-time asset that they've been
working with we run it on the absolute
queue and the data is perfect no need to
optimize and again that's because the
underlying biochemistry is pretty much
the same
and in terms of developing any newer
assays really the guidelines that you
would use for designing an assay with
real time would also apply to digital so
anything about the primer sequences the
length the sequence context all that is
pretty much going to be the same for
digital as it was for real time
all right great thank you and your last
question today what is dead volume and
why is it important for a digital PCR
yeah we briefly alluded to the idea of
dead volume where let's say in a system
we're going to load 10 microliters of
our reaction mix into the instrument or
into the plate to get experiment get
assessed
some instruments might take say 10
microliters and then only actually
utilize and get data from a fraction of
that maybe half that volume or something
like that because some of that volume
maybe wasn't effectively incorporated
into a sub-reaction and if that
sub-reaction isn't usable for one reason
or another and it doesn't make it to the
final end of the data analysis that
volume from that sub-reaction is
considered dead volume or any other
volume that never makes it into any
sub-reaction at all dead volume
with the absolute Q system we talked
about that there's
over 95 percent of the volume is truly
utilized and actually gets data
associated with it so that's less than
five percent of that being dead volume
and that's important for two reasons one
is reagents they cost money that dead
volume consists of your assay mix and
your master mix so that's money going
away secondly if you're looking at rare
targets if you've only assessing 50 of
what you loaded you're going to have a
lot more uncertainty a lot more
variability and if I detected my target
was it in that 10 microliters but not in
the five Market leaders assessed now you
just have another level of variability
another sub sampling issue to keeping
track of whereas with our system we're
having over 99 percent
actually 95 of that volume utilized so
we don't have that concern
well thank you again Dave for your time
today and your wonderful presentation we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor of Thermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labords will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye